un día después de lascarcelación masiva
de 222 presos políticos el régimen
autoritario de Daniel Ortega ordenó a
más de 26 años de prisión al obispo
Rolando Álvarez para ordenar que el
acusado Rolando José Árboles lagos se
mantenga bajo prisión la justicia
nicaragüense acusó a Álvarez una de las
voces más críticas de la Iglesia
Católica local por cargos como traición
a la patria o de propagar noticias
falsas despojándolo también de su
nacionalidad y sus derechos políticos el
obispo se opuso a dejar Nicaragua junto
al resto de descarcelados que el jueves
fueron enviados a Washington siendo
también despojados de su nacionalidad
desde Estados Unidos el líder
estudiantil Max Jerez relató a France 24
los momentos más duros durante su
detención efectivamente uno de los
momentos más difíciles probablemente de
mi vida fue el fallecimiento de mi mamá
y realmente puedo decir que no solo no
me permitieron ir a sentirlos no solo no
me permitieron saber que ella estaba
pasando su último momento sino que
tampoco pude conocer que había fallecido
en el momento exacto de su fallecimiento
Y si bien los opositores y críticos de
Ortega celebran su Liberación reconocen
que el país necesita un diálogo profundo
es una profunda derrota porque no se
puede traducir de otra forma y sobre
todo yo espero y estoy
consciente de que Nicaragua necesita una
salida una medida así no es la solución
que Nicaragua no es la única solución
que Nicaragua necesita los presos
políticos son solamente uno de los
síntomas del profundo problema que
encierra Nicaragua bajo la dictadura de
Antonio Ortega España por su parte se
ofreció a darles la nacionalidad a los
desterrados por el régimen sandinista
ante la perspectiva de convertirse en
apátridas incluso a los 23 internos que
Todavía siguen privados de libertad por
motivos políticos